[Music]
[Music]
sadly
in the next 18 minutes when i do our
chat
four americans
that are alive will be dead
through the food that they eat
name's jamie oliver i'm 34 years old
i'm from essex in england
and uh
for the last seven years i've worked
fairly tirelessly to save lives in my
own way i'm not a doctor
i'm a chef
i don't have expensive equipment
or medicine i use information education
i profoundly believe that the power of
food has a primal place in our homes
that binds us
to the best bits of life
we have an awful
awful
reality right now
america
you're at the top of your game
this is one of the most unhealthy
countries in the world
can i please just see a raise of hands
for how many of you had have children in
this room today please put your hands up
aunties uncles you can continue to put
your hands up aunties and uncles as well
most of you
okay
we
the adults of the last four generations
have blessed our children
with the destiny of a shorter life span
than their own parents
your child
will live a life 10 years younger than
you
because of the landscape of food that
we've built around them
two-thirds of this room today in america
are statistically overweight or obese
you lot you're all right but we'll get
you eventually don't worry
right
the statistics of bad health are clear
very clear
we spend our lives being paranoid about
death murder homicide you name it it's
on the front page of every paper cnn
look at homicide at the bottom for god's
sake
right
every single one of those ones in the
red
is a diet related disease any doctor any
specialist will tell you that fact
diet-related disease is the biggest
killer in the united states right now
here today
this is a global problem
it's a catastrophe it's sweeping the
world england is right behind you as
usual
i know they were close but not that
close
we need a revolution mexico australia
germany
india china all have massive problems of
obesity and bad health
think about smoking
it costs way less than obesity now
obesity costs you americans 10
of your health care bills 150 billion
dollars a year
in 10 years it's set to double 300
billion a year and let's be honest guys
you ain't got that cash
[Applause]
i came here
to start a food revolution that i
so profoundly believe in we need it the
time is now we're in a tipping point
moment i've been doing this for seven
years i've been trying in america for
seven years now is the time when it's
right
right for the picking i went to the eye
of a storm i went to west virginia the
most unhealthy state in america or it
was last year we got a new one this year
but we'll work on that next season
huntington west virginia beautiful town
i wanted to put heart and soul and
people
your public
around the statistics that we've become
so used to
i want to introduce you to some of the
people that i care about your public
your children i want to show a picture
of my friend brittany she's 16 years old
she's got
six years to live
because
of the food that she's eaten
she's the third generation of americans
that hasn't grown up in a food
environment where they've been taught to
cook at home or in school or her mum or
her mom's mom she has six years to live
she's eating her liver to death
stacey the edwards family
this is a normal family guys
stacey does her best but she's third
generation as well she was never taught
to cook at home or at school the
family's obese justin here 12 years old
he's 350 pounds he gets bullied for
god's sake the daughter there katie
she's four years old she's obese before
she even gets to primary school
marissa she's all right she's one of
your luck but you know what her father
who was obese died in her arms and then
the second most important man in her
life her uncle died of obesity
and now my stepdad is obese
you see the thing is
obesity and diet related disease doesn't
just hurt the people that have it it's
all of their friends families brothers
sisters
pastor steve
an inspirational man one of my early
allies in huntington west virginia
he's at the sharp knife
edge of this problem
he has to bury the people okay
and he's fed up with it he's fed up with
burying his friends his family as a
community
come winter three times as many people
die
he's sick of it this is preventable
disease waste of life
by the way this is what they get buried
in
we're not geared up to do this
i can't even get them out the door and
i'm being serious can't even get them
there forklift
okay i see it as a triangle okay this is
our landscape of food i need you to
understand it you've probably heard all
this before but let's just go back over
it over the last 30 years what's
happened that's ripped the heart out of
this country let's be frank and honest
well
modern day life let's start with the
main street
fast food has taken over the whole
country we know that the big brands are
some of the most important powers
powerful powers in this country
supermarkets as well
big companies big companies uh you know
30 years ago most of the food was
largely local and largely fresh now it's
largely processed and full of all sorts
of additives extra ingredients and you
know the rest of the story portion size
is obviously a massive massive problem
labeling is a massive problem
the labeling in this country is a
disgrace
they want to be self they want to self
police themselves the industry want to
self police themselves
what in this current climate they don't
deserve it
how can you say something is low fat
when it's full of so much sugar
home
the biggest problem with the home is
that used to be the heart of passing on
uh food food culture um
what made our society that ain't
happening anymore and you know as we go
to work and as life changes and as life
always evolves
we kind of have to look at it
holistically step back for a moment and
readjust the balance it ain't happening
hasn't happened for 30 years okay
i want to show you
a situation
that's very normal
right now the edwards family
let's have a talk
this this stuff goes through you and
your family's body
every week and i need you to know that
this is going to kill your children
early
how are you feeling
i'm just feeling really
sad and depressed right now
that you know i want my kids to succeed
in life and this isn't going to get them
there but i'm killing him
yes you are
you are
but we can stop that
normal
let's get on schools
something that i'm fairly much a
specialist in uh okay school
what is school who invented it what's
the purpose of school school was always
invented to arm us with the tools to
make us creative be i do wonderful
things make us earn a living etc etc etc
you know it's been kind of in this sort
of tight box for a long long time okay
but we haven't really evolved it to deal
with the health catastrophes of america
okay um school food
is something that most kids uh 31
million a day actually uh have twice a
day more than often breakfast and lunch
180 days of the year so you could say
that school food is quite important
really judging the circumstances
um before i crack into my rant which i'm
sure you're waiting for
[Applause]
i need to say one thing and it's so
important in in hopefully the magic that
happens and unfolds in the next three
months
the lunch ladies the lunch cooks of
america
i
offer myself as their ambassador
i'm not slagging them off they're doing
the best they can do
they're doing their best
but they're doing what they're told and
what they've told what they've been told
to do is wrong
the system is highly run by accountants
there's not enough or any food
knowledgeable people in the business
there's a problem if you're not a food
expert and you've got tight budgets and
it's getting tighter then you can't be
creative you can't duck and dive and
write different things around things if
you're an accountant and a box ticker
the only thing you can do in these
circumstances is buy cheaper [ __ ]
now the reality is is this the food that
your kids get every day is fast food
it's highly processed there's not enough
fresh food in there at all you know the
amount of additives e numbers
ingredients you wouldn't believe there's
not enough veggies at all french fries
are considered a vegetable pizza for
breakfast they don't even get given
crockery knives and forks no they're too
dangerous
there's scissors in the classroom but
knives and forks no
and the way i look at it is if you don't
have knives and forks in your school
you're purely endorsing
from a state level fast food because
it's handheld and yes by the way it is
fast food it's sloppy joes it's burgers
it's wieners it's pizzas it's all of
that stuff
ten percent of what we spend on
healthcare as i said earlier
is on obesity and it's going to double
we're not teaching our kids there's no
statutory right to teach kids about food
elementary or secondary school okay we
don't teach kids about food
right and this is this is a little clip
from an elementary school which is very
common
[Music]
who knows what this is
potatoes potato so you think these are
potatoes
do you know what that is
do you know what that is broccoli what
about this good old friend do you know
what this is honey
no what do you think it is
onion no
immediately you get a really clear sense
of do the kids know anything about where
food comes from who knows what that is
uh
here what do you think this is
i don't know if the kids don't know what
stuff is then they will never eat it
normal
england and america
england and america
guess what fix that guess what fix that
two one-hour sessions
we've got to start teaching our kids
about food in schools period
i want to go i want to tell you about
something i want to i want to tell you
about something that kind of it kind of
epitomizes the trouble that we're in
guys okay i want to talk about something
so basic as milk
every kid has the right to milk at
school your kids will be having milk at
school breakfast and lunch right they'll
be having two bottles okay and most kids
do but milk ain't good enough anymore
because someone at the milk board right
and don't get me wrong i support milk
but someone on the milk board probably
paid a lot of money for some giza to
work out that if you put loads of
flavourings and colorings and sugar in
milk right more kids will drink it
yeah
and obviously you know now that's going
to catch on the apple board is going to
work out if they make toffee apples
they'll eat more apples as well do you
know what i mean
for me
there ain't no need to flavor the milk
okay there's sugar in everything i know
the ins and outs of those ingredients
it's in everything even the milk hasn't
escaped the kind of modern day problems
there's our milk there's our carton in
that is nearly as much sugar as one of
your favorite cans of fizzy pop and
they're having two a day so let me just
show you we've got one kid here
having
you know
eight tablespoons of sugar a day
you know
there's your week
there's
your month
and i've took the liberty of putting in
just the five years of elementary school
sugar
just from milk
now i don't know about you guys but
judging the circumstances
right any judge in the whole world
would look at the statistics and the
evidence and they would find any
government of old guilty of child abuse
that's my belief
now if i came up here and i wish i could
come up here today and hang a cure for
aids or cancer
you'd be fighting and scrambling to get
to me
this all this bad news is preventable
that's the good news
it's very very preventable
so let's just think about we got a
problem here we need to reboot
okay so in my world what do we need to
do here's the thing right um it cannot
just come from one source to reboot and
make real tangible change
real change so that i can look you in
the white of the eyes and say in 10
years time the history of your
children's lives happiness and let's not
forget you're clever if you eat well you
know you're going to live longer
all of that stuff it will look different
okay
so
supermarkets where else do you shop so
religiously week in week out how much
money do you spend in your life in a
supermarket
love them they just sell us what we want
all right
they owe us
to put a food ambassador in every major
supermarket
they need to help us shop they need to
show us how to cook quick tasty seasonal
meals for people that are busy this is
not expensive it is done in some and it
needs to be done across the board in
america soon and quick
the big brands you know the food brands
need to put food education at the heart
of their businesses i know easier said
than done it's the future it's the only
way fast food
with the fast food industry
um you know it's very competitive i've
had loads of secret papers and dealings
with fast food rest you know restaurants
i know how they do it i mean basically
they've weaned us on to these hits of
sugar salt and fat and x y z and
everyone loves them right so these guys
are going to be part of the solution but
we need to get the government to work
with all of the fast food purveyors and
the restaurant industry and over a five
six seven year period wieners off the
extreme amounts of fat sugar fat and all
the other non-food ingredients now also
back to the sort of big brands labeling
i said earlier is an absolute fart and
has got to be sorted
okay school
obviously in schools we owe it to them
to make sure those 180 days of the year
from that little precious age of four to
18 20 24 whatever they need to be cooked
proper
fresh food
from local girls on site okay there
needs to be a new standard of fresh
proper food for your children
under the circumstances it's profoundly
important that every single american
child leaves school knowing how to cook
10 recipes that will save their life
life skills
that means that they can be students
young parents
and and be able to sort of duck and dive
around the basics of cooking no matter
what recession hits them next time if
you can cook
recession money doesn't matter if you
can cook time doesn't matter
the workplace we haven't really talked
about it you know
it's now time for corporate
responsibility to really look at what
they feed or make available to their
staff the staff are the mums and dads of
america's children marissa her father
died in her hand i think she'd be quite
happy if corporate america could start
feeding their staff properly definitely
they shouldn't be left out let's go back
to the home now look if we do all this
stuff and we can it's so achievable you
can care and be commercial absolutely
but the home needs to start passing on
cooking again for sure for sure pass it
on is a philosophy
and for me it's quite romantic but it's
about if one if one person teaches three
people how to cook something you know
and they teach three of their mates that
only has to repeat itself 25 times and
that's the whole population of america
romantic yes
but most importantly
it's about trying to get people to
realize that every one of your
individual efforts makes a difference
we've got to put back what's been lost
huntington kitchen
huntington where i made this program you
know we've got this prime time program
that hopefully will inspire people to
really get on this change i truly
believe that change will happen
huntington's kitchen i work with the
community i worked in the schools i
found local sustainable funding to get
every single school in the area from the
junk onto the fresh food six and a half
grand per school
that's all it takes six and a half grand
per school the kitchen is 25 grand a
month okay this can do 5 000 people
a year which is 10 of their population
and it's it's people on people you know
it's local cooks teaching local people
it's free cooking lessons guys free
cooking lessons in the main street
this is real tangible change real
tangible change
around america if we just look back now
there's plenty of wonderful things going
on
there's plenty of beautiful things going
on there are angels around america doing
great things in schools
farm to school setups
garden setups uh education there are
amazing people doing this already the
problem is they all want to roll out
what they're doing to the next school
and the next but there's no cash
we need to recognize the experts and the
angels quickly identify them and allow
them to easily find the resource to keep
rolling out what they're already doing
and doing well
businesses of america need to support
mrs obama to do the things that she
wants to do
and
look
i know it's weird having an english
person standing here before you
talking about all this all i can say is
i care
i'm a father
and i love this country
and i believe truly actually
that if change can be made in this
country
beautiful things will happen around the
world if america does it i believe other
people will follow it's incredibly
important
when i was in huntington trying to get a
few things to work when they weren't
i thought if i had a magic wand
what would i do and i and i thought you
know what i just love to be put in front
of some of the most amazing movers and
shakers in america
and a month later ted phoned me up and
gave me this award
i'm here
so my wish
dyslexic so i'm a bit slow
my wish
is for you to help a strong sustainable
movement
to educate every child
about food
to inspire families to cook again
and to empower people everywhere
to fight obesity
thank you
[Applause]
you